do a shout out to ask IJ o ask I J hey
what are these these is all these P
speaks out of grass kg that's right
not gonna lie I definitely feel it
I'm dancing around singing my theme song
and
welcome to episode number 10 I do not
live from the beach and I've a few
announcements to make before we start
into the question the winner of the
profs is cover paper here
Brad's one star so congratulations Brad
one star you lucky winner
the chain Power Rangers lightsaber the
second announcement of another smuggle
contest for the ladies all right let's
get into the show let's start off with
our first question I've got this paper
in front of me because I can't bring the
computer to the beach from a cat comp do
you have to prep before your videos what
do you do and how long does it take
though I do I read through all of your
performance on YouTube all of your
Twitter questions and watch all of your
responses
our youtube comment which comes from a
new to gay autumn there was once alive
we could marry
the Kelly Clarkson
hey Justine I just wanted to ask you
what's your favorite song on your iPod
or your Mac or your iPhone or so you
wanna know my favorite song is my iPhone
all right we're gonna have to go a
little old-school here
you
asked question yeah my internet friends
I have a question for you you know this
is
Sega technologies No
CEO of a company Oh stick jockey as some
of you might have seen on my other by
Justine YouTube channel I went on a
Virgin America flight
and on this white I got a huge bag it
has a bunch of goodies to make up iPod
cases sunglasses the ones that I'm
wearing right now bracelet
mother stuff okay all right this is
getting ridiculous
I'm getting scared
10th episode hope you guys enjoyed my
feed tradition special guests cheap jobs
see you guys next time don't forget
leave your comments below make those
video responses and ask the questions on
Twitter so don't forget ladies you want
to win the bag of goodies make video
responses